who's going to get slapped at the Oscars
tomorrow hopefully Will Smith
you want us to forgive you why don't you
just let Chris Rock smack you on the
Health on TV
crazy
children
I'm sorry where's the LIE
her son's best friend with a drug habit
and we gotta feel bad for her just
because she bald God took your hair you
predatory ass
there we go we didn't give her cancer
because she is a cancer
[Applause]
like the empress in Lilo and Stitch hurt
Jayden you've let in your mouth by your
friends that's crazy we're just over
here playing Legos
crazy he came to my house played
PlayStation then he put his joystick in
your mouth
[Applause]